[Musique]
ici à valmer effectivement plus de
château donc j'ai décidé de restituer la
structure de cette façade pour que quand
on arrive l'oeil soit à nouveau arrêté
par un volume et de façon à ce que ça
rééquilibre l'espace évidemment j'ai
planté des ifs parce que je n'ai pas
résisté à la blague d'avoir un château
d'if la caractéristique principale de
ces jardins c'est une succession de
terrasses de 8 niveaux des parts du haut
du coteau jusqu'au niveau le plus bas
qui est celui du potager
[Musique]
la façon dont on a dessiné les terrasses
hauteur largeur est fait de telle
manière que de n'importe où dans le
jardin on ne voit pas le potager il en
arrive à masquer un hectare de jardin ce
qui est un tour de force d'un point de
vue paysagiste
[Musique]
les valeurs de l'antiquité et du born
essais en italie et c'est ça qui est
apportée ici par rapport au jardin
médiéval le jardin italien s'ouvre vers
le paysage et profite de vue lointaine
un jardin intérieur reste intime reste à
échelle humaine
alors que souvent un jardin à la
française va devenir souvent un peu
mégalomane
heureusement pour valmer les
propriétaires du 19e siècle manquer
d'argent et du coup ce jardin ont
échappé à la dix-neuvième lisation si on
peut dire et c'est assez peu fréquent
que des jardins de cette taille là soit
rester absolument dans leur jus oui
c'est très possible que léonard de vinci
et dessiner ses jardins tant que je n'ai
pas le papier signé de sa main
je ne le dit pas mais effectivement le
propriétaire de l'époque étaient étaient
très proches que françois 1er donc
devait ouvrir léonard de vinci tous les
jours et je veux pas croire que comme il
envisageait de faire des jardins quand
même assez important
il n'est pas demandé un petit croquis à
léonard
[Musique]